what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano
most of you know me as pump you're
listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off
Chris slaughter is the CEO of level a
crypto Exchange where users get
unlimited trading for one monthly fee in
this conversation we discuss exchange
business models the competitive
landscape holes that currently exist in
the market what level does differently
and what the company's future plans are
I really enjoyed this conversation and I
hope you do as well skirt school want to
know who has the best URL crypto com
that's right crypto comm they're a
crypto platform with one goal mother in
mass adoption that's why we're all here
we're trying to get crypto in every
wallet crypto calm is helping people do
that through buying earning lending and
card payment everything you could want
at crypto comm go help your boy out
tell them pomp since you download the
app or visit crypto calm the pumps got
you always everyone to get into mining
and didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine com tell them Tom sent
you and thank me later as many of you
know crypto investors store their
digital assets on exchanges or in cold
storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or Ethernet block
five and receive 6%
interest paid monthly in cryptocurrency
6% is an absurdly high rate it's the
best rate in the industry I highly
suggest you go check out block Viacom /
pump again that's block 5 com / pop to
sign up and start earning crypto today
if you follow Bitcoin and crypto
you've probably heard of eToro they're
the world's number one social trading
platform and I love it
they've got more than 10 million other
traders that love it - and guess what
they just launched the united states
eToro offers access to the world's most
popular crypto currencies including
Bitcoin etherium and others with the
smartest trading tools and the ability
to connect with the best traders around
the world there's no better place to
build your perfect portfolio if you're
new to Bitcoin and crypto you can test
the waters with their $100,000 virtual
trading feature but if you're more
experienced you can create custom
technical charts and use eToro social
fees to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available on an
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks
at each or Oh calm again that's eToro
com get VIP access to Bitcoin and crypto
markets today Anthony Pappalardo
is a partner at Morgan Creek digital all
opinions expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only
alright guys bang-bang super excited to
have Chris on the podcast today we've
got a whole bunch of stuff to talk about
but thank you so much for taking the
time to do this sir
no I really appreciate it thanks for
having me on for sure let's start with
on your background what would you do
kind of pre Bitcoin and crypto so I went
to school for Applied Mathematics and
studied that at the undergrad and
graduate level and then I started an AI
company called Lynx labs and that went
on to develop a lot of the like tracking
and recognition technology that powers
things like the
ceci vive headset or oculus the oculus
rift and so that was that was a
successful venture and then I left I
left that AI work I guess when everyone
was getting into AI I was getting out of
it and it took a sabbatical and then
during my sabbatical was was when was it
was basically the 2017 run so I had had
an opportunity to buy Bitcoin like much
earlier I had bought and sold like just
for fun but I had an opportunity to take
a position in Bitcoin in like 2013 and
obviously I got rent by not having a bag
going into 2017 so then it had my full
attention and decided to do a company in
crypto focused on like broadening
consumer adoption for sure now it's
interesting that you described getting
rekt by not having exposure to the
upside I don't think I've ever heard
anyone describe it that way yeah I mean
I guess it's a it's an opportunity cost
my buddy wanted to sell me Bitcoin and I
didn't have enough time to research it
and so I like just declined to purchase
it and it would have been a really good
outcome and so hindsight is 20/20 but
now I'm a really strong believer that
you know the price of Bitcoin goes up as
adoption the utilization go up and I
just think that that's the trend that's
indicated now for sure
that makes a ton of sense all right so
let's talk a little bit about what
you're building at level and kind of
where you guys are you know to date like
what have you guys actually built and
what's the model that you're using sure
a great question so levels levels
mission is to create a easy-to-use
financial services platform under a flat
and transparent fee model so that means
we focus on user experience is easy to
just pick up and use and we charge a
flat model of a $9 a month subscription
fee which is very different from sort of
the rest of the world of Finance which
is based on transaction fees the product
we have today it is live it's in alpha
it's available by invitation it allows
you to do krypter krypter trading
amongst
numerous assets so we've got Bitcoin
Bitcoin cash aetherium litecoin and USD
C and we have a limit order trading on a
full spot market we run our own spot
market and then we have automated
strategies that make it easier to do
things like market make which are tools
that traditionally sort of like
algorithms and Wall Street guys would
use so that's our that's our sort of
beachhead product it's a lot of like
crypto early adopters and whales that
are on it right now and then in the in
our sort of short term roadmap we're
also adding checking accounts
that'll be FDIC insured and debit cards
and I mentioned this just because it's
to emphasize the sort of our mission is
to reform financial services under like
a low and transparent fee so we have a
vision that goes beyond cryptocurrency
for sure and let's talk a little bit
about that the reason why you're using
the model you're using and some of the
other business models in the space with
competitive products around listing
freeze and the predatory nature of them
and you get a ton of thoughts there
maybe just walk us through how you view
the difference sure so so I mean in
business you have the business that
you're conducting which is like the
services that you offer to consumers and
then there's the business model so
exchanges banks they're in the business
of offering financial services but the
way they make money is usually to
exploit lack of knowledge of the retail
customer to like extract the maximum
amount of profit out of that end user so
I'll give a couple examples so when you
go to apply for a mortgage at a bank
they try to get you into a variable rate
which like appears at the front door to
be the best mortgage you can get but you
end up paying a much higher rate in the
back end if you can't keep twelve
hundred dollars a month in your Bank of
America account every day they charge
you twelve dollars at the end of the
month so that's like a 1% monthly
negative interest rate coinbase
for example you know you've got coinbase
Pro where you have about point two
five percent transaction fee on 'pray
but they've got exactly the same
offering they've got exactly the same
offering on coin based consumer that
charges like a minimum of two percent
but if you're not doing big transactions
it can be up to ten percent so what's
interesting about this is all of these
fees are based on like transactions but
the technology behind financial services
doesn't have costs that like scale and
the volume of transactions so for
example on coin base if you do a ten
thousand dollar trade or you do a
million dollar trade both of those have
the same cost to the exchange which is
you know they just decrease one database
entry and increase another database
entry we're talking about milliwatts
effectively zero cost but they introduce
these transaction fees and then
introduce their tier them across
customer segments basically to exploit
the fact that less advantaged users are
less knowledgeable about these fee
structures so coming in as Outsiders we
looked at exchanges and just the like
level of complexity that goes into
processing financial transactions and
you know we're talking about milliwatts
to database operations per trade and you
know compare that to something like
World of Warcraft's where you're flying
around on you know dragons and fighting
hundreds of thousands of other virtual
players or Netflix where they're putting
$7 out of the nine dollars that they get
a month directly into content production
and edge Network delivery so exchange is
you know first of all are making like 96
percent gross margin which is you know
just way on the high end it's just
clearly exploitative because they have
you know sort of early time to market so
there's clearly collecting much more
profit than they need to sustainably
operate and they're also just more comp
or less complex than something like
World of Warcraft or Spotify so our
approach is different in that we charge
a flat $9 a month fee and all trading is
all treating is zero dollars and as we
add additional services that will be
included in that flat
$9.00 pity so we're bringing sort of the
Netflix model to finance got it and so
what is the like play devil's advocate
for a minute right the point of business
is for a corporation to make as much
money as possible obviously and you've
got to balance that with serving your
customers right so there's a definitely
a balance and sometimes even a
counterbalance to those two things I
think what you're saying is basically
look these are highly profitable
businesses and some of the business
models are predatory in nature only
because there's such high margin and
they're really built on this idea of
like information arbitrage right do you
think a lot of that gets changed as more
competition comes in and there's kind of
compression of margins and things like
that or do you think that there's a
business model shift that needs to
happen that can really change this and
then ripple through the rest of the
industry well I think it's I think it's
definitely both and so sort of removing
removing how you think about these
things philosophically like just
capitalist forces are gonna drive down
price as technologies and platforms get
commoditized
so do you look at something like Finance
they competed at entry with just
charging like historically low fees for
the market so that was like a low fee
volume play and that put other exchanges
under pressure particularly secondary
exchanges to lower prices so without
even having a philosophical position
like that is something that that's
something that we've seen in industry so
far is just prices going down through
competition you know it's interesting
that you mentioned sort of like will it
take a business model change and I think
business model changes are the changes
that have the most potential to disrupt
so music when we were in the iTunes era
it was all transaction based and we just
know sort of factually that there was
more utilization of iTunes than there
was of record stores before it but then
when the Spotify model came along
utilization went up even higher and so
it
it was viewed as a better value for
consumers but it ultimately drove higher
revenues for the music industry as well
so I think that I guess the ribbon
summary I think that natural competition
will lower prices but fundamental new
business models tend to have the
greatest like disruptive impact for sure
I I definitely grew that and what do you
think in terms of the the information
arbitrage how can how can that be
reduced or at least kind of eaten into
is it simply just adding transparency to
what the fees are on each transaction or
soar something else that you think is is
important um I mean market education is
important so if you talk to crypto
traders that want to trade on a
regulated US exchange they tend to trade
on coinbase
and what you'll find out is that the
longer them in trading the much more
likely they are to to trade on coinbase
Pro versus coinbase consumer they know
that it has like all the same features
as coin based consumer they're
sophisticated enough for the more
technical interface and they want to
save the money and so that's an example
of how education like eliminates the
barriers between sort of like noobs and
and experienced traders and you know a
lot of these business models are really
predicated on just like wrecking noobs
so I think I think education over time
turns the noobs into pros that that's
just a natural dynamic but it you you're
left with two problems first of all
there's always going to be new noobs
that's why they're noobs and second of
all for the market to expand everybody's
a noob so I think I think what you have
to do is you have to introduce products
that where their business model is not
dependent on information asymmetry and
consumers adversely selecting the more
expensive option and like the coin based
consumer versus the coin based bro
and the way we do that at level for
example is is we have consumer while it
buys themselves and we have a technical
interface and on coin based Pro those
are treated from like different wallets
the
two different siloed experience but on
level you can use the noob interface and
you can use the pro interface and in
both cases the transaction fees are zero
so I think that's just an example
obviously we're gonna advocate for our
products we're excited about it but I
think it's just an example of how you
can design products that still have a
viable business model but eliminate sort
of this exploitation of information
asymmetry for sure
in with your model kind of that Netflix
like model or a flat fee model you've
gotten a number of pretty high profile
advisors to sign on maybe give us an
overview of who those are yeah so we're
really excited about our advisory board
we have willy woo is a blockchain
analytics pioneer jimmy song who is a
blockchain developer and educator we
were recently joined by John Price who
was the founder of trilogy software in
Texas so one of the biggest tech
companies in Texas history and and the
reason we recruited this advisory board
is my my co-founder Courtney and I have
always had success in business by
forming advisory groups of customers
that know more about the industry than
we do so we came in in 2017 which makes
us sort of like crypto carpetbaggers and
one of the one of the very first things
we wanted to do was get to know people
that had positive reputations that were
focused on education that understood how
to build good products in the space and
we're really lucky to get Willie and
Jimmy involved early and now the
advisory board is much larger as well
we've got a number of seasoned
executives on it and one thing I'd like
to emphasize is that you know this is a
2017 notion of what a Crypt advisor was
which is somebody would have this new
speculative ico token like let's say
like Katt coin and you'd see this lineup
of eight advisors that were basically
using her Twitter platform to say that
this was like the new hot ICO token and
and then they were out of the business
in a matter of months because they would
just take their allocation of tokens
sell it on an exchange and piece out
that
not what traditional advising is our
advisors are traditional business
advisors so their equity they're
compensated in equity not cash and the
equity conversations through options
that they won't be able to exercise for
a while so everybody on our advisory
board including William Jimmy who have
been with us for over a year they
basically are involved because they
think that the company will have a
positive impact if it's successful and
they think their participation will has
a will improve the likelihood of success
and so the the advisory board is very
committed we meet on a weekly basis but
but basically we're all riding the
outcome of the business together we're
all equally invested as shareholders for
sure and I think it's also you're
describing it more from like how people
perceive the advisory board and what
they do but but also from a founder seat
right there's a huge difference between
somebody willing to tweet about your
business and somebody willing to
actually help you write and give advice
and introductions and and help move the
business forward when you have the right
advisors and they know what they're
doing
it can be an inflection point for the
business and for the founders oh no
absolutely you know we came into this
business we knew how to code we knew how
to raise money but there's a lot of
things we didn't know how to do and and
it's it's had a real impact on the
products like our crypto custodian bit
Co we decided to work with them through
a relationship that Jimmy had most of
our consumer interface was built with
like Willie's insights we hold these
weekly calls where Willie just tears
down the product and then we try to
rebuild it in time
for the following week so I think
there's a real value i I like it I like
working advisors I have my whole career
and I think if you approach it in the
right way there's a way to be judicious
to the adviser each time but just
rapidly accelerate the the sort of
degree of knowledge of the business for
sure now it makes a ton of sense all
right let's move on to you guys have
obviously on the exchange side you have
it been quite disruptive in your thought
process around the business model but
you're not just going to build an
exchange
there's plans to build a number of other
products maybe talk a little bit about
what those products are and any
timeframe or
roadmap that you can give us when the
Asha get launched sure so level at its
core is the financial services business
we help people solve financial problems
by offering financial services and we
have this like flat business model of
nine bucks a month and right now that's
a cribs exchange and the reason it makes
sense to start in crypto is is fees are
just so obscenely high in crypto and the
people that buy Bitcoin are like the
smartest finance customers out there so
that's the reason you want to start in
crypto but ultimately what we want to do
is we want to reform the way that
financial services are offered in the
same way that Vanguard reformed the way
that financial advising was offered so
I'll just talk about something like the
medius and immediate next steps on our
sort of Honor trajectory so by the end
of this year we'll introduce FDIC
insured checking accounts so unlike the
cash accounts on other exchanges these
are full deposit accounts insured by the
FDIC where you could keep your cash
receive incoming paychecks basically
become a replacement for your Wells
Fargo account and then we're also going
to introduce debit cards that can spend
from either your checking account or
from your Bitcoin and so you know I
think I I think I think what this is is
really sort of a platform that like
merges together a lot of different
financial services in a frictionless
experience in a similar way to like
maybe the iPhone brought Internet
communication and regular phone calls
under one roof and when you create a
frictionless experience like that it
just makes it easier to adopt the
technology because it does more for
customers so one thing I'd like to
emphasize is that you know offering
checking accounts and debit cards and
Bitcoin alongside each other it's not
necessarily a hedge you know I think
that Bitcoin will
place cash I think that's just a simply
inevitable thing to happen but along the
roads along along the road to getting
there you want to have seamless gateways
between cash and crypto so you know if
you're the restaurant your app doesn't
take Bitcoin you want to be able to
spend from your Bitcoin on a debit card
if you need to take out cash to like
let's say like wire it to a family
member you shouldn't have to pay a $35
wire fee to get cash from coinbase to
Wells Fargo and then another fee to send
it from Wells Fargo so the the the basic
idea here is is to sort of bring the
more of the finance under one roof so
that it's frictionless for people to
explore the future of money for sure and
then how do you think about things like
the Fiat on-ramp and off-ramps right so
what I mean by that is one of the ways
that people can you know get into
Bitcoin and and the cryptocurrency
industry is they could obviously take
their fiat currency they can convert it
as they go to an exchange and they buy a
Bitcoin for example the other being they
kind of earn within that ecosystem right
so there's all kinds of different
products that are doing that but one
that I'm fascinated with as an idea is
really this if you get paid in a digital
currency you are actually unlikely to
convert that back to fiat right like it
feels like that is a big mental shift
and that is also a really big liquidity
functionality where people are likely to
stay in the currency that they get paid
in rather than switch back and forth
depending on certain criteria no I I
totally agree with that and I think that
example you just gave us somebody
getting paid in Bitcoin and then wanting
to sort of stay long in Bitcoin is a big
industry problem that needs to be solved
because there's a lot of people that
believe in the fundamental dynamics of
Bitcoin that believe that as more people
adopt it it'll continue to be robust and
secure but owing to its finite supply
that its value will increase so you know
it's a liquid asset like cash that also
has like a speculative nature based on
pretty good
fundamentals so you know you described
sort of an on-ramp on to Bitcoin and a
way to stay long Bitcoin and then what's
missing right now is sort of the
off-ramp side so you can get paid for
your job in Bitcoin you can hold your
Bitcoin in a wallet but it's hard to get
rapid like liquidity when you go to a
restaurant because they just aren't
taking Bitcoin yet
I think that'll change eventually I I
honestly don't know the timeframe but I
think generally what you want to do is
make it make the boundaries between cash
and bitcoin is like frictionless as
possible so in the scenario you
described you should be able to stay
long Bitcoin if you believe in the asset
class but still be able to like pay for
dinner on a debit card and then on the
on ramp side what you want to eliminate
is is wire transfers from from one bank
to a crypto institution and you want to
eliminate like high predatory
transaction fees for the faster methods
so like the three point nine nine
percent fees you see when you buy crypto
in Bitcoin those should be eliminated as
well you know I think the I strongly
believe that Bitcoin will be the world's
standard currency but interest sort of
counter intuitively what you need to do
between here and then is remove the
friction and switching between the two
yep yeah I think of things like debit
cards that they're basically like a
band-aid solution because really what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
use the currency of choice which is
Bitcoin and that technology is
incompatible or not accepted by a legacy
payment provider right whether it's a
point of sale or some other mechanism
and so really what that credit card is
doing is it's a bridge right it comes in
the same format but it's pulling from
the choice currency and so over time
hopefully the importance of those
bridges becomes less and less important
but that will only be driven by the fact
that that legacy system starts to accept
the new currency right if that doesn't
happen then you're gonna continue to
need that bridge between the two
technologies your currency systems no
that's like exactly right and I think an
okay analogy for this is like I don't
know this is a good analogy or not but
public transit so I I grew up in Dallas
and the dart line which is our Rapid
Transit System there is a point in time
where there's only one line then there
is a point in time where there were two
lines and you know they cross in the
middle and now there's nine lines and
azza has gotten more connected people
have shifted from driving so riding the
dart so the analog in this industry is
like let's say that we introduced
accounts where it's easier to just spend
your Bitcoin on a debit card then
there's going to be more people that are
holding Bitcoin and then when more
people are holding Bitcoin there are
their costs efficiencies and stores just
accepting Bitcoin off like outright
basically it's gonna end up that
lightning Network is cheaper than the
interchange system so you know just like
just like Bitcoin a Bitcoin is sort of
inevitable because it's a way to sort of
short the flaws in monetary and fiscal
policy sort of short government money
and it's sort of designed to avoid the
problems and government money I think
that more vendors taking Bitcoin is also
inevitable because as the utilization
increases it's a way to eliminate the
sort of like rent-seeking behavior that
happens in interchange skirts girl want
to know who has the best URL crypto comm
that's right crypto comm their crypto
platform with one goal mother mass
adoption that's why we're all here we're
trying to get crypto in every wallet
crypto comm is helping people do that
through buying earning lending and card
payment everything you could want at
crypto comm go help your boy out
tell them pump sent you download the app
or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a Playstation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box
you plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi
five minutes or less you're mining
Bitcoin all you have to do is control it
from the mobile app they provide and
then you receive over-the-air updates
that add new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine com tell
them pom sent you and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor block buy
their new interest account allows you to
securely deposit your Bitcoin or either
at block 5 and receive 6% annual
interest paid monthly and cryptocurrency
this rate actually compound so you
receive a 6.2 percent bpy which is very
attractive given the alternatives so you
can actually take your Bitcoin you can
deposit it with block Phi and get paid
an interest rate of 6% in return go
check out block 5 comm slash pop again
block 5 comm slash pump to sign up and
start earning interest on your crypto
today but where else do you see
people either being taken advantage of
or a high degree of kind of information
arbitrage putting individuals at a
disadvantage in the industry to be
totally honest it's it's really a big
issue in crypto currency and what's
interesting is you see a lot of the same
the same issues and crypto currency that
got regulated away in the securities
industry they're all popping up again in
crypto and so just some examples I mean
we want to win over the example of sort
of like coin base being designed for
people to adversely select the platform
with the higher fees but by dance for
example they have much lower fees but
they list a lot of sort of securities
tokens and you know they claimed they
weren't securities but if you look at
their finance US launch plan you know
there's only like 6 assets that they're
planning the list which is kind of a
concession that everything else all
these other [ __ ] coins are really
securities and you know by Nantz
admitted publicly I think in an
interview with Laura Shen that they were
taking multi-million dollar listing fees
for taking those onto the
platform so this is a little bit of a
complex form of information arbitrage
but you know what finance basically was
doing was saying okay we'll list
whatever you want us to list as long as
you pay us a couple of million bucks and
then we listed on our exchange so that
you have liquidity to our own consumers
and those consumers will buy it because
it got bought because it got listed on
Finance
that is a fundamental conflict of
interest and it also was not publicly
known that finance was like listing and
saying assets were of high quality
simply to get paid and the the outcome
is obvious if you look at the
performance of assets on Finance other
than Bitcoin all but two assets have
lost their value and the average is
something like 95 percent of value so
Finance is sort of this like halfpipe
made of poop where it's like fun as long
as you can stay on your skis but the the
fundamentals of Finance because they
have this conflict in the asset
listening they're the quality of the
assets that they list the fundamentals
are that on a value basis all their
customers are going to lose money it's
just a sort of really whip-smart day
traders which must be less than half if
you look at the hard numbers those are
the guys that that come out ahead so I
think that's like a really complex form
of information asymmetry you know
another example was during the ico boom
of 2017 was a lot of sort of crypto
celebrities attaching their name to two
projects as a sort of like business
advisors when really what they're doing
was just promoting the ICL and then
taking liquidity as soon as it got on
Finance and so that's an example of like
an undisclosed conflict as well and
what's interesting about this is if you
look back at like the 1910s 1920s 1930s
all those problems existed and then we
got the banking act the investment
advisors Act the Securities Exchange Act
basically all these these laws there are
legal terms that correspond to all of
this activity so like what finance is
doing is sort of like statutory
underwriting what these IC advisors
doing is sort of like a
securities promotion they all are based
on information arbitrage and they all
have been regulated out of existence in
the in the securities industry so I
think what we'll see over time is that
you know world governments will work
together to say like look kripp does a
good thing and you should be able to
trade it but we need to at least meet
the standards of in terms of customer
abuse we need to at least meet the
standards of traditional industries for
sure well knowing that there are other
areas where there's kind of that
information arbitrage what do you think
our other products or areas of
innovation that either you guys are
going to take a look at or other
entrepreneurs will will seek so I think
like an obvious way that we combat this
is our business models free of those
conflicts you know we use some you can't
pay us to list your asset and and then
also we're just trying to make it easier
to get into trading so it makes it sort
of like safe space I think that's gonna
have an impact on adoption and a release
it at least like eliminates some of the
abuse that we see among the early
adopter segments but outside of us
entirely I think I think a really
exciting thing that's coming is
investment services so bitwise today is
available to accredited investors claim
base index fund is available to credit
investors there are there are many
people trying to get an ETF listed and
they're facing resistance from the SEC
in terms of like how legitimately priced
or these assets do the market
manipulation on exchanges but like let's
assume that that eventually gets through
then that's gonna be really a pretty I
mean you can't call any investments safe
but it's gonna be a pretty safe way to
invest because these are gonna be either
ETFs of Bitcoin or they're gonna be
geeks yes of a couple different large
caps that have a strong history of
appreciating in value because they're
based on you know fundamental protocols
that appreciate his utilization goes up
so this is not something levels doing I
mean we do this stuff it's like passive
advising tools within our plan
but I think what we're gonna see is a
general push where crypto ETFs get
listed as they meet the standards of the
SEC where we're gonna see people like
Wells Fargo Advisors going to are gonna
start introducing their own customers
into crypto as an asset class and I
think that just lowers the sort of
barrier of entry and it also creates
like a circuit breaker for for [ __ ]
you know the these companies these
companies are under a lot of regulatory
scrutiny not to engage in some of the
activity we see in the unregulated
crypto exchanges for sure it feels like
there's gonna be a kind of before
regulatory crackdown and after
regulatory crackdown life right it's a
it gonna be one date or if it's just a
period in time but but definitely agree
with you that there is a you know a
whole bunch of nonsense going on that
eventually will kind of get regulated
away and it's not a bad thing for the
mark it's actually a good thing right
because the the people who actually have
the large dollars are not going to be
able to come in until there's more kind
of clarity at a minimum and also
prevention of a lot of that nonsense and
so I think that's a big moment at the
balance though is you don't want to
regulate out any sort of maybe not
advantage but but just access that
individuals have right so if you look at
like the accreditation laws for example
those are obviously a huge barrier for a
lot of people to some of the best
investment opportunities and so you want
to kind of strike this balance between
you want clear safe markets but you also
want the ability for anyone to
participate regardless of wealth
location education etc yeah I think that
that's one of the really big
difficulties in crypto and I think to
Jake Lee in the SEC Chairman's credit
like he is at this this point you just
made about like how does the little guy
get access that's why they're excited
about crypto to begin with you know he
gave a he gave a talk where he said well
yeah and you would expect him to say
like look the accreditation rules are
there to protect consumers and
you know that's the reason that we made
them to begin with but I saw this talk
he gave where he had a really surprising
position on it he said if he said you
know people are gonna want to
participate in these markets it would be
better that we revisit the accreditation
rule and and open the markets up some
more people so that we can regulate the
types of assets that people are
interested in so I think there's a sort
of like steampunk libertarian pushback
against regulation because regulation is
viewed as an inhibition to the market
but what regulators really want to do is
they want to keep markets healthy and
they want to protect consumers so you
know they and and and also also
regulators have been focused on retail
for a long time because it substantially
has improved the health of financial
markets so it's not like they're just in
the service of sort of like Wall Street
fat cats although it can sometimes
appear that way so I I think I think if
you watch what regulators are doing
their intentions are well are sort of
like pure and I think that they're gonna
try to tackle problems in a way that are
sensible but frankly it's an extremely
messy process like along the way there's
just horrendous clarity from regulators
and some of the some of the regulatory
directives now aren't even can't even be
implemented for sure no I I think you're
spot on what products do you think can
help drive some of this adoption right I
know that you feel pretty strongly about
the idea that the adoption in the market
is quite low kind of you know mid to
maybe even low single digits global
population what are the products that
you see that could help us get up into
the double digits of percentage-wise of
adoption over the next couple years yeah
this is a really great question so I
mean what one thing that the
appreciation of value of Bitcoin
strongly correlates with is the number
of people that adopt it and there's a
lot of different theories behind this
like some people think of scales like
Metcalfe's law like a like a square the
number of participants some people think
it's a store of value so it has a finite
supply that will ever be minted and so
just more more people transacting in it
is going to drive the price up
but it's just it's statistically clear
that the more people get into Bitcoin
the the higher the price goes which
makes the sector healthier so I think
that establishes that a goal should be
to expand the market and and so I think
what you have to start with is just like
what is the maturity of the market now I
love this book called crossing the chasm
by Geoffrey Moore and basically the sort
of hypothesis behind Jeffrey Morse book
is that technologies get all the way up
to saturating early adopter
participation which is usually about
like 15% of the addressable market and
then there's a chasm that you have to
cross and that chasm is how do you make
the technology take the technology from
just being something that's exciting
that's new that nerds adopt because they
just believe in the future and turn it
into something that solves like a
real-world problem and I think that's
where we are in the market you know in
developed countries like it's something
like 35 percent of people are open to be
natively digitally banked and then we
see three percent penetration of crypto
so the numbers work out to be like
roughly ten to fifteen percent of
adoption of the addressable market so it
lines up exactly with early adopter
saturation the numbers work out and
we're seeing like things like staking
and custodial offerings where exchanges
are now trying and lending like things
like blocked by where people are really
trying to get more value out of the
early adopter base what I think has to
happen is we need to take it from early
adopters which is like tech literate
mostly male sort of like 12 to 40 year
olds and we need to turn it into like
products and assets that would be of
like more broad appeal and like the the
biggest way to accomplish that like just
fundamentally is to improve ease of use
if you can build platforms where it is
easier and it's cheaper to buy Bitcoin
more people will do it and because the
price will be going up right so people
are gonna watch MSNBC they're gonna see
that bitcoins going up and then the
barrier that's left you know the thing
that's holding the dam
is just too dang hard to go sign up for
a bye Nance account so I think things
like Libre cash app what we're doing at
level what we're really trying to do is
crack that new frontier of building
products that are elegant enough for
general consumer Steve's for sure what
do you think is kind of the one thing
that somebody is working on where you're
like wow if that works that's going to
lead to a massive increase in adoption
is there one product that's out there
that you think kind of encapsulates that
or do you think it's a culmination of
many many different products and
different teams all working on their own
aspects of this and then together we get
the adoption so when you have big
adoption spikes particularly in like
today's tech environment they tend to
follow a power-law so it tends to be
that like a couple products will take
the lion's share of adoption and so in
the last wave of the early adopter wave
that would have been like coinbase
Kraken and to a lesser extent vetrix I
think that I think that you know the
product that is gonna see mass adoption
isn't out yet as just evidenced by the
lack of like sort of dramatically order
of magnitude new adoption but I think
there are several products that are
doing exciting things coinbase for the
last several years has been like the
easiest to use product to get people
into crypto and I think they're gonna
continue to try to improve their user
interface and what they're doing in apps
I think cash app is doing something
that's like interesting and
differentiated and they're making a lot
of money doing it
I like that if they do they allow sort
of like real blockchain transfers and
it's integrated against like a cash
account
I don't like they're like spread
charging model but so to answer your
question like I don't think I don't
think the sort of killer app is out
there yet I think that the ingredients
of the killer app are like sort of being
developed at various different companies
and I think when the formula gets
cracked what we'll see is two or three
platforms that that really carry crypto
into the next wave of adoption
and capture the lion's share of of new
interests for sure before I wrap up I
always ask rapid-fire set of questions
what do you think is the most important
company encrypting other than your own
over the last several years its
undisputably clintus you think coinbase
why what they've done to lower the sort
of technical ease-of-use barrier century
and allow people to go from cash to
crypto in the regulated sphere has just
dramatically expanded the market got it
what's the one regulation you would
change or improve if you could the
travel rule so the the recent guidance
is that the recent guidance is that when
you send crypto from one exchange to
another exchange you have to you have to
include the accompanying identifying
customer information which in banking is
done with swift in crypto is not
possible to do that if we were to send
our customer information in an encrypted
unencrypted script of Bitcoin during the
transfer then we would be publicly
disclosing this is the front with
blockchain so we'd be publicly
disclosing their information which is a
violation of another set of policy is
called PCH and if we were to send it
encrypted then without some type of key
sharing approach the other exchange
can't even make sense of it so we
certainly don't need laws that are
impossible to follow for sure what a
what's your most controversial thought
in Bitcoin and crypto geez well we run a
marketplace so it's it's important for
us that the it's important for us that
like we don't take views towards
specific assets well I would say I would
say outside of Bitcoin litecoin
dogecoin Bitcoin cash things that are
clearly protocols when you start getting
into the ERC 20 tokens
most of those are securities and if they
look a lot like penny stocks and they
they aren't capturing intrinsic value I
think that's a hike bubble and not only
is it a high bubble it's it's been
mostly popped to the extent that they've
gone down like 98 percent in value
across the board yeah it's pretty crazy
what's the most important book you've
ever read there's a book called daring
greatly which is about it's about is
about like understanding vulnerability
and the way that it like affects your
behavior and that how like sort of
embracing vulnerability can make you
like a better leader a better partner
it's kind of mushy stuff but I think
it's I think for that reason a lot of
people don't think about it a lot and I
would highly recommend that book it's
had just an incredibly positive
experience on my life also I've not read
that one I'll have to check that one out
before I finish up I always let everyone
ask me a question but we talked a lian's
first believer non-believer
okay obviously there's aliens like there
has to be a lien so like deep down in
the ocean when there's like this
pressure so high that we can't even send
a submarine there there's and there's no
oxygen there's like critters that it
evolved to like live off like carbon
dioxide coming out of heat vents so the
idea that you know the universe is you
know ten to the twenty three times
bigger than Earth and life exists here
pretty much where it shouldn't it seems
to me inevitable that that there is
alien life and you know I think this
sort of like corollary question is like
well what if they just don't care about
us yeah well I I always joke and I'm
cheating in the sense that I've had the
pleasure of asking you know literally
almost 200 people at this point about
aliens I talked about it more than I
ever thought I would but but one of the
things and I forget who said it
they just said look you know what if the
aliens know we're here and they show up
a lot of times in history the person who
went to a new land it didn't turn out so
well for the people who were in that
existing land right and kind of the
Conqueror and so I think we always you
know think of aliens as as friendly or
as people who who know things I guess
that we would interact with but but it
might not be so tame and maybe a little
bit more hostile than than we're
anticipating I think that's also super
likely it must unless they sort of
psychologically were fundamentally
different from humans in every way every
news like think about how humans treat
every species on earth that we consider
ourselves superior to and our natural
resources
so if an alien showed up tomorrow that
means that they're more sophisticated in
terms of like technology than we are and
you know based on the information we
have to go on on intelligence they
probably wouldn't treat us that well
yeah for sure what a what one question
you have for me to finish up so I know
you're an active investor and you run
this podcast which is kind of like a
it's really focused on the industry and
I've listened to a bunch of it and it's
pretty objective I'm just curious like
how you balance your role is like an
active investor with running a
journalistic like media venture yeah so
um first off I explain to everyone you
know pretty often like I'm not a
journalist right so I am gonna be biased
I I have the great fortune of my
girlfriend is um one of the the
technology journalists at a major
publication and so we talk a lot about
it actually kind of the the differences
between you know the journalistic
standards that are holding a lot of
those publications to versus what I'll
call you know something more like this
podcast and simple things like you know
if I hear something I can pull my phone
out and I tweet it right and it's kind
of the conversation happens on Twitter
where people agree or disagree and
provide evidence supporting or
detracting from it etc whereas I think
that in her world you know if she's told
something she goes and she checks with
two to three sources confirms it you
know and kind of goes doing a whole
editorial process etc so it's very I
think different from a process
standpoint the second thing is you know
I I try to be as transparent as possible
in terms of you know what we've invested
in write to me that's like the one big
and like kind of that danger area but
just an area that I need to be very
cognizant of and so what I've found
actually is that the audience they
really appreciate when we've taken money
and invest in it all right so we're kind
of we have capital on the line or skin
in the game and so a lot of times I try
to talk about you know hey look we've
invested in this business this is
founder they're gonna you know discuss X
Y or Z I think the harder part for me is
actually when we don't invest right so
there's a number of founders that we
spend a lot of time with we evaluate
their businesses we do these deep
diligence you know kind of projects with
them we ultimately decide not to invest
and you know I'm pretty good and don't
think I've ever used any sort of
insensitive information or anything in a
podcast but definitely having an
understanding of how people think about
their business or think about the
industry what I try to do is be very
careful about not making any sort of
claims or assessment on how they think
and moreso trying to let everyone use
the platform to describe their views in
their words right and a lot of times
I'll even tell people that where it's
just like look this is a chance for you
to talk about what you believe and how
you see the industry etc this isn't for
me to argue with people or tell them
they're dumb or tell them that I
disagree with them etc and I think that
that leads to a little bit of backlash
sometimes like people get really mad if
somebody comes on says some stuff that
either I don't agree with or somebody
else doesn't agree with but I do think
it's important to allow listeners to
hear you know you know every kind of
viewpoint and then ultimately decide
what they believe is valuable and true
and what they don't believe is valuable
and true yeah that's a super detailed
and interesting answer especially the
emphasis on transparency Thanks yeah
it's a something that I probably spent
more time thinking about than that I'd
like to admit frankly now looking Chris
this has been this has been super
exciting I really enjoyed this
conversation I think you've got a lot of
great ideas around some of the market
dynamics at play and then obviously the
business model that you guys are
pursuing is uh is really intriguing so
I'll have to have you come back on in a
few months when they you guys mix more
progress great I'd appreciate that thank
you so much for having me on pop hey
everyone pop here if you like this
episode of off the chain and want to
help us to take crypto to the top of the
Apple Spotify and other podcast charts
please do us a favor and rate review and
subscribe to review simply go to the
off-the-chain homepage scroll down until
you see the five blank stars taking 15
seconds to fill those stars in and leave
quick review goes a long way in helping
us take the entire crypto ecosystem to
the top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time on off
the chain